[موسيقى]
كريستيانو يتصدر عناوين السوشيال ميديا
مجددا كره يد مارادونا تباع باكثر من
مليونين دولار ونيمار يتمنى هزيمه ميسي في
نهائي المونديال هذه الاخبار وغيرها
تتابعون من العربيه الرياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
يتصدر عن نون السوشيال ميديا بعد بث
مقابله المنتظره كامله كريس المقبل على
منافسه كاس العالم اكتسب بعد ان جدد في
فريقه يونايتد حيث طلب زملائه من الاداره
من العوده بعد المونديال وبسخ عقده او
ايجاد اي طريقه لرحيله وحتى زميله وحتى
زميله وفي المنتخب في ريال مدريد سابقا
رافايران هجمه خلال المؤتمر الصحفي لمنتخب
فرنسا
تصريحات رونالدو يبدو انها لم تعجب حتى
المتابعين من خارج مانشستر يونايتد بعد
تصريح مسؤول في نادي مانشستر سيتي لشبكه
اي اس بي ان نفهم من خلاله تصريح
كريستيانو الذي قال فيه بان سيتي حاول
جاهدا التعاقد معه العام الماضي
وبعد نحوي اسبوعين من بدء المزاد العلني
بيعه الكره التي سجل بها مارادونا هدفه
مقابل مليون و300 الف دولار وكانت تونسيه
علي بن ناصر حكموا مباراه الارجنتين
وانجلترا قد احتفظ بالكره لمده 36 عاما
قبل ان يقرر مشاركته مع العالم وبيعه
الكره في دار المزادات تقراها بعد الواقع
في العاصمه البريطانيه
تخيل ان تواجه في نهائي كاس العالم ونفوز
عليكم هكذا رسم نيمار سيناريو نهائي كاس
العالم بين البرازيل والارجنتين وكلامه
مواجا لميسي لكنه كان عبر الهاتف وقال
نيمار لسعد التلغراف لانه لم يتحدث مع مسك
كثيرا حول كاس العالم لكن كان يمزح معه
بخصوص طريق كل منهما نحو النهائي
[موسيقى]